our next guest is no stranger to
shattering glass ceilings cynthia
marshall became the first black female
ceo of an nba team in 2018. dallas
mavericks owner mark cuban hired her to
transform the team's toxic work culture
under marshall the mavericks leadership
team is now 50 women and 47 people of
color forbes has named her one of the
world's 15 most inspiring female leaders
and adweek called her one of the 30 most
powerful women in sports but here's the
thing she has broken barriers all her
life marshall was the first black
president in her high school and the
first black cheerleader at uc berkeley
and in her new book you've been chosen
thriving through the unexpected marshall
shares personal stories of resilience
that helped shape who she is today saint
marshall joins us right now good morning
how are you doing good morning i'm doing
fabulous how are you all doing great
thank you for joining us now you were
hired by mark cuban
to help change the culture now is this
true that at the time you didn't really
know much about basketball and if that's
the case then why did he feel like you
were the perfect person for the job and
he didn't know who mark cuban was okay
i'm a basketball fan but i didn't know
the business of basketball and i did not
know mark cuban so don't judge me i just
didn't but i know him now yeah i know
and he knows me yeah but i took it
because it was an opportunity uh to make
a difference and when mark laid out the
position and he was very sincere about
changing the culture i had done similar
work at at t which is how he got my name
and two women stopped me as i was
leaving his office and told me their
stories
and said you have to do this for us and
so i am you know i immediately said you
know let me go home and pray about it
because i pray about everything of
course and i came back and talked to the
employees the next day and for three
hours
i just heard different stories and i met
these wonderful people we have amazing
people at the dallas mavericks
and i said yes i said yes i said yes for
the sisterhood but it turned out to be
for
everybody and so it's been an amazing
experience with all these fabulous
people uh working to make a great place
to work i i don't take the credit for it
at all you've got the three principles
of leadership that you live by listen
learn and love do i have those rights
yes my three l's of leadership yes if i
to be an effective leader i need to
listen to the people and truly listen at
a very deep level listen to really
understand them i had one-on-ones with
every single maverick employee when i
got there and so to listen to the people
learn from the people i mean back in the
day i went to pole climbing school at
atnt just to learn you know what people
actually do every day so i could have
empathy for them and then to love them
to love them as people not as employees
but to love that person who gets up out
of bed in the morning that's who i want
to walk into our doors and so we have to
truly truly love them you know when mark
was here he was raving about you so i
really couldn't wait to meet you but
your book the the chosen is so
key i think to your life you had a very
abusive father who used to beat the crap
out of your mother you given vivid
detail broke your nose one time
you you talk about uh being diagnosed
with cancer colon cancer you survived
that you've had four miscarriages and
had a baby on the fifth time second
trimester miscarriages yes that baby
little carolyn did not live you've now
adopted uh four children but i also look
at what you've done in the corporate
world and this is what fascinated me
about the book early on in your career
you were told
uh do not wear braids take the braids
out of your hair do not wear red shoes
because they're not professional today
you're wearing hot pink shoes hot pink
that's really good you make it good man
you like these yeah yeah i'm making a
statement so that was early on sent yeah
and then later you get this big
promotion and you said that when she
called the person to give you the
promotion you could tell she wasn't
happy for you but what did she tell you
you needed to do in order to get the
promotion well she had left a magazine
on my desk so she told me that she
wanted me to look like the people on the
cover and so there were these black
people in all white
somebody had a short haircut so she
wanted me to cut my hair of course i
didn't want to do it my husband was in
the background saying i have a barber i
have a barber we can do this i'm like no
no this is she wants you to change your
name you want me to change my name so
she said i couldn't be sent because
nobody knows what ascent is i have to be
cindy or cynthia i can talk that loud i
can have all these people in my office
not laugh too loudly couldn't laugh too
loud she said i was just too happy and i
needed to be a little more stoic stop
saying the word blessed stop saying
blessed i need i stopped saying lucky
that i mean stop saying blessed that i
needed to say i was lucky so when
somebody tells you all of that scent
marshall when somebody tells you all of
that and you turned down the promotion
you turned down the progress you said
thanks but no thank you but when you've
gotten all these obstacles to overcome
what keeps you so enthusiastic and so
focused and so confident about what you
do well i think it's a it's a faith that
i have that i got from my mother uh that
no matter you know what happens uh it's
always going to come out better on the
other side and so and that's the what
the book is all about that i've been
chosen for this adversity we've all been
chosen uh for adversity but we're
uniquely a qualified to deal with it and
so it just uh it's a faith but and
knowing that i serve a purpose but you
were going to retire you were supposed
to retire when mark cuban called you you
have a four-year contract yes i was
retired and i started my own business
but i was called to do it i truly well
you know to do it we are glad that you
didn't retire sent marshall we
appreciate you thank you so much you've
been chosen on sale tomorrow and on
today's cbs morning's podcast saint
marshall shares the role that faith has
played in her professional and personal
life yeah thank you cindy thank you
thank you sister i like your green shoot
okay thank you very much